officially alex sharma has less than 24
hours to negotiate a deal to limit
global warming to 1.5 degrees
and every minute will count
we are not there yet on the most
critical issues
there is still a lot more work to be
done
a key fight remarkable after 30 years of
climate conferences is about whether a
final agreement can even mention the
words fossil fuels
even in the supposedly progressive eu
there are disagreements on that wording
there is strong opposition to it well
there's strong opposition against
everything in the text so we have to
find a compromise that reflects our
ambition and i think our ambition should
include
our commitment to put an end to coal and
to put an end to subsidies for fossil
fuel old battle lines are being redrawn
will saudi arabia continue in its
efforts to remove any mention of fossil
fuels from the text is there any hope
that australia historically obstructive
could soften its position or any chance
that russia might do the same
and remember there's more than 190 other
countries each with their own asks and
what are green lights for some are red
lines for others and it's that
diplomatic spaghetti that alok sharma
and his presidency team have to try and
disentangle and get an agreement on
even if and it's a big if wording around
cutting fossil fuels and coal survives a
lack of money for developing countries
is still a total deal breaker so the
commitment that the u.s and other
countries have made so far fall short
of the 1.5 degree trajectory
and therefore
we urge and call on those countries
to raise their ambition
one thing is becoming clearer glasgow
won't seal the 1.5 degree deal the fight
is likely to be for an agreement that
forms a foundation on which it can be
built but fast i think the successful
glasgow in my view is to recognize that
gap very very clearly
just to really make
a big effort to come back next year in
with a big
push
it sounds a lot like the blah blah blah
the campaigners complain of
but it's the reality of this un-led
process to get consensus on fixing
global warming and for now it's the only
game in town
tom clark sky news glasgow